Mach die Gewichte gross, ach sie riesengross, dann pumpen wir so gerne, dann ist hier mal was los. Oh, mach die Gewichte gross, ja, dann macht sie gross, dann pumpen wir so gerne, dann ist hier mal was los. Guten Tag, herzlich willkommen. Der Zochkütz, der Zochkütz, Kölle Alav. Kölle ist stark, sage ich mal. Liebe Grüße an alle, die uns gerade in der Muckibude hören, die richtig pumpen. Los, eins, zwei, drei, geht noch mehr. Schön, dass ihr mit dabei seid. Endlich kommt zusammen, was zusammen gehört. Gyms und Karneval. Ja, endlich mal. Habe ich das richtig interpretiert? War das ein Karnevalchor? Das war ein klassischer Karnevalsumzug, der natürlich auch, da gibt es ja immer den einen, der immer den Stock hochwirft. Wenn der einfach ein bisschen schwerer wäre, wäre das, glaube ich, ein gutes Workout. Würde ich mich auch sofort anmelden, wenn alle so. Oder es ist der einzige, der kein Instrument spielen kann, ist wahrscheinlich der gängige Gag in Kapellen. Stefan Tietze sitzt mir gegenüber. Ja, und Florian Will sitzt mir gegenüber. Aber nicht konfrontativ, es ist jetzt keine ... Nee, also nicht jetzt so, nicht weder politisch noch irgendwie diskursiv oder so. Wir sitzen uns einfach rein räumlich gegenüber. Wir sitzen auf zwei Seiten des Tisches. Das ist eine rein geometrische Situation. Genau, ich meine, es ist eine gerade... Ja, da wollen wir jetzt nicht ins Detail gehen, aber erstmal vielen Dank an alle, die uns zuhören. Und vielen Dank an Robin, der dieses Intro komponiert hat, der immer endlich mal wieder die Trommel aus dem Keller geholt hat und einen schönen Marsch komponiert hat. Denn Tanzen und Bewegung, Fortbewegung ist ja sehr nah beieinander. Ja, und das für alle Leute, die uns jetzt zum ersten Mal hören, das besitzt sich darauf, dass Flo und den die geniale Idee hatte, wie ich finde, Gewichte im Fitnessstudio einfach grösser zu machen. Nicht schwerer, nur grösser, damit sie schwerer aussehen. Und dann gibt es dieses eine Fitnessstudio, ist dann ganz kurz, bis es sich rumspricht, Trend, so Instagram-Trend. Ja. Weil alle machen Fotos mit sich in Riesengewichten
und dann dreht man es um und es ist eigentlich nur Luft.
Das sind immer nur Plastikgewichte, wo nichts drin ist.
So Fisher-Price-Gewichte und die wirklich schweren Gewichte sind aber besonders klein.
So dass du dir immer überlegen willst, will ich tatsächlich trainieren oder will ich nur was darstellen?
Klingt spannend, aber auch sehr nervig.
Weil man die ganze Zeit kontra-interotiverweise zu Gewichten greift, wo man nicht weiß,
sind die jetzt schwer, sind die jetzt leicht. Alles ist weird. Du kannst teilweise auch die Maschinen, an denen man trainiert, hochheben einfach, easy. Menschen, die rumlaufen, Trainer, kann man hochheben und dann so wie so Luftballons kann man so wegschieben und dann gehen die an die Decke machen, so knauschen die an die Decke und sowas. Es ist alles verspiegelt und der Boden ist uneben. Also der Boden ist einmal komplett schief, damit auch die Leute und die die schweren Gewichte sind weiter hinten und sehen dadurch viel kleiner aus, weil einfach da die Decke auch näher, die Decke ist grösser, also so ein Gefälle nach hinten und die sehen ganz winzig. Und verjüngt sich nach hinten. Es gibt eine Verjüngung. Und die sind ganz winzig klein und es gibt auch so Treppen, die sozusagen immer mal wieder sich selbst besteigen können und es ist einfach sehr verwirrend. Es gibt diese eine Treppenstufe, die ein bisschen höher ist als die anderen, weshalb man da immer stolpert. Es ist ein grosser Spaß für alle, die nicht da drin sind. Ja genau, es ist sozusagen ein experimentelles Gym. Es ist ein Kunstprojekt. Es klingt nach Phantasial und Crazy House. Sag mal, warum gibt es eigentlich nicht gute, bewährte Konzepte aus der Kindheit für Erwachsene? Die Erwachsenen-Hüpfburg? Wenn du sagst, ich gehe heute Abend, äh, Schatz, ah scheiße, jetzt stand ich eine Stunde lang im Stau und der Mr. Jakamoto hängt mir schon wieder wegen den Deadlines der Quartalszahlen im Nacken. Bernhard Jakamoto? Genau, genau, hängt mir wirklich im Nacken, Mann, der macht mich fertig, ob ich da noch weiter arbeiten will. naaja, ich gehe jetzt erstmal in die Hüpfburg und dann kann ich mich so ein bisschen abreagieren. Rennsportart Hüpfburg. Und einfach dann gehen alle wirklich so super gestresste Businessleute, hängen ihren Anzug auf und dann springen sie einfach in so einer riesigen Hüpfburg rum, schubsen erlaubt. Ja, auf eine Art finde ich ist ja, jetzt ist es nur gelernter, aber so ein Fahrrad, so ein Ergometer, so ein Fahrradergometer, was da rumsteht, wo man sozusagen, was ein Fahrrad ist, auf Stelzen, damit es nicht weiterfährt, ist ja auf eine Art so ein Kinderspielzeug auch. Ja. Also so Kinder machen ihren Kram, es ist wie diese Küche, diese kleine Kochinsel, wo dann so ein kleines Mädchen dran sitzt und was backt oder so. Genau, die aber nicht angeschlossen ist.
Die nicht angeschlossen ist.
Genau so wie ist das Fahrrad nicht am Boden angeschlossen.
Genau, es ist so ein Spaß, aber so ein bisschen zweckentfremdet, aber es ist noch ein Fahrrad,
bitteschön, und deswegen verstehe ich auch gar nicht, warum man nicht das auch Hüpfbogen
macht, völlig richtig.
Warum denn nicht?
Also einfach wirklich gross und es macht ja auch Spaß oder so grosse Trampoline, gut,
ihr sagt es Verletzungsgefahr und da muss nur einer seine Spikes angezogen haben. Immer Verletzungsgefahr. Auf jede Idee. Angsthasen sei dir. Es muss nur jemand irgendwie einen Saboteur, nur eine Nadel mitnehmen und dann ist der Spaß zu Ende. Das ist natürlich das Problem, bei Erwachsenen gibt es viel mehr Saboteure. Beim Ergometer müsste man nur unten diese Stelzen abschneiden, dann radeln die alle da im Fitnessstudio rum. Das wäre mal ein Prank, oder? Am 1. April, falls ihr einen Gym habt, macht mal am 1. April die Fahrräder, stellt die mich auf den Boden und dann guckt mal in die grossen, schweissnassen Augen, wenn die Leute tatsächlich anfangen zu fahren und sie denken, wow, und überhaupt nicht wissen, was sie tun sollen. Das ist Fun für mich. Das macht Spaß. Das ist grossartiger Fall. Aber ich habe gerade gedacht, was wir beschrieben haben, war ja so ein typisches Freizeitpark-Crazy-Haus. Da gibt es ja diese Häuser, wo alles ein bisschen, alles steht Kopf. Manchmal wortwörtlich, weil dann ist das Bett oben und dann sind die Treppen komisch und die Spiegel sind lustig. Ich hätte viel mehr Spaß an der Nachbildung von einem sehr, sehr guten Hotel, was ich mir nicht leisten kann. Also du gehst auf den Rummel, hast Zuckerwatte in der Hand, gebrannte Mandeln in der anderen, bist gut drauf und sagst, oh, lass uns ins Hilton gehen für fünf Euro pro Person und dann hast du so die President Suite. Wenn die Idee ist, Welten kennenzulernen, auf die ich für mich normalerweise keinen Zugriff habe, die Mittelalterwelt, die da ist, hab ich keinen Zugriff drauf. Gibt es nicht.
Dieses Crazy House, was es da gibt, hab ich keinen Zugriff drauf.
Zeig mir ein Crazy-Ass-Bali-Hotel, was ich mir nicht leisten kann, mit einem Infinity-Pool.
Da würde ich rumlaufen und Fotos machen, hätte ich gesagt.
Und dann eine Achterbahn durchs Ritz-Carlton, einmal durch die Lobby.
Und du einfach so, der erwachsenste Ride ever, einfach so.
Alle stehen da, wow, das Marmor. Oh, das ist Marmor. Oh, das ist der gute Marmor aus. Oh, das ist ja toll. Barlo, Barli, ich weiss es nicht genau. Nee, aber ich finde das... Oh Mann, auf eine Art Marmor her, ich wusste das mal, weil ich da immer vorbeigelaufen bin. Hey Siri, hey Siri, okay Siri, was geht Siri, okay Google.
Nee, ich bin ja tatsächlich früher in Berlin immer joggen gegangen und dann bin ich an einem Hotel vorbeigelaufen und ich glaube es war das Ritz-Carlton am Potsdamer Platz.
Dann bin ich immer vorbeigelaufen, um da in diesen Park zu kommen und da bin ich immer an der Ecke vorbeigekommen, wo so an dem Hotel stand, dieser Marmor ist Gewinner des Preises Marmor des Jahres 2014 oder sowas. Von allen drei Contestants. Von allen, die dabei waren. Und dieser Marmor wurde, ich glaube, in irgendwie Sardinien oder in Sizilien oder irgendwie in Sini. Ich bin so über das Wert, was jetzt kommt. Sowas geschürft und dann da hierher verfrachtet und dann in Passform gehauen quasi. Und ich dachte mir immer so. Geschürft, verfrachtet, gehauen. Genau. Und ich dachte mir immer so, wenn man das da dran schreit. Wo geht's zu Cave Sea? Und immer wenn ich das gelesen habe, dachte ich mir, soll ich mir die Spicy Wings Wings oder die Original Recycy Wings holen? Angenommen, ich würde jetzt, jetzt würde Professor Eich von mir stellen und mich fragen, welches Startup-Bokemon, wie würde ich mich jetzt gerade entscheiden? Gestern war es klar, Bisasam. Ich habe immer Bisasam genommen, aber wenn er mich wirklich, also jetzt mal wirklich ernst genommen, ernst mal, mich wirklich jetzt fragen würde, wüsste ich nicht, was ich ... Warum starren Sie unseren Marmor an? Hören Sie auf unseren Marmor anzustarren. Ach so. Das Gewinner des Pulitzerpreises. Ja, und ich dachte immer so, ein bisschen lame, wenn man das so da hinschreibt. Oder, wenn man an den Marmor hinschreibt, ich bin der beste Marmor der Welt, Gewinner des Jahres, so, lass das doch einfach ... Für sich sprechen. Lass das für sich sprechen, wenn der Marmor für sich mich nicht beeindruckt, dann finde ich, sollte auch nicht sein Lebenslauf dranstehen und sagen, oh, ich bin so toll, weil allein, dass du das schon sagen musst, macht dich schon weniger wert, lass mich dich doch einfach genießen und dann irgendwo mal durch einen Zufall herausfinden, aber ich dachte, jedes Mal, wenn ich vorbeigelaufen bin, dachte ich mir, ach wie schade eigentlich, der muss das immer vor sich her tragen, eigentlich ist ja so eine Trophäe
auch ein Fluch, weil natürlich
du diese Trophäe immer Leuten zeigen
willst und guck mal und hier und so
und gar nicht mehr du für dich selber stehen kannst.
Ja, vor allem, wenn du eine krasse Trophäe
bekommen hast,
die es wert ist, darüber zu reden, musst du sie
vielleicht nicht vorzeigen, weil Leute dich dann dafür kennen.
Ein Marmor und nehmt das von den beiden Marmor-Kondisseuren, Florian Will und Stefan Dietze, das das Podcast-Ober-Podcast-Podcast-Projekt ist, weil Marmor, auf dem steht, woher er kommt, ist nicht wert. Ich mag ja das Prinzip Poker zum Beispiel, wo wenn du gewinnst, kriegst du kein Trophäe, sondern du kriegst so ein Armband. Und das trägst du dann einfach ganz normal, wie ein Armband. Und beim nächsten Turnier trägst du dieses Armband, dann sitzt du halt am Tisch und hast dieses Armband an. Und es ist so, dass man sagt, dein Armband, hättest du jetzt so ein Pokal einfach auf deinem Schoss, dann würden Leute denken, Entschuldigung, warum haben sie ein Pokal dabei? Wohin ging das Armband, ist clever genug, einfach sich als normales Und der neunzehnfache Weltmeister sitzt da so. Komplett steifene Arme. Ich komme mit steife Arme, wie so jemand, der beide Hände gebrochen, beide Arme gebrochen hat, sitzt dann da so, weil er sich nicht mehr bewegen kann, weil er immer verdonnert ist, diese scheisse Arme zu tragen. Ja, so ein bisschen, da überschneiden sich auch Pokerspieler und Festivalbesucher, die einfach unerträglich viele Armbänder haben und die jedem ins Gesicht halten und zeigen, guck mal, ich war da. Und ab einem gewissen Punkt wird es ekelhaft. Ab zu vielen Armbändern denkt man sich, die musst du ja schon seit Jahren am Handgelenk haben. Wir freuen uns sehr, dass das deutsche Eiskunstlaufpaar Anna Gorminkhofer und Sebastian Scheck hier heute gewonnen haben. Und hier sieht man sie auf der Gewinnertribüne und wie es üblich ist beim Eiskunstlauf wird ihnen nicht ein Pokal im Bereich, sondern wir sehen hier die beiden goldenen Nasenringe. Sehr schön, wunderbar. Wunderbar gearbeitet und hier werden sie. Da kommt der Nagel, der Tradition in der Nagel. Zack und. Oh, da sah er schmerzhaft aus. Blut auf dem Eis. Aber es friert sofort. Es friert sofort. Naja, ja, sehr schön. Sie haben sich tatsächlich beide für die linke Seite entschieden, ungewöhnlich, aber ich gönne es Ihnen. Ich gönne es mit ganzem Herzen. Das ganze Training hat sich gelohnt. Ja, der Dreifach-Drechsler in der letzten Runde, wie sie gemeinsam im Kreis pirouisiert sind, das hat mich hypnotisiert. Das hat mich hypnotisiert und Gott sei Dank hast du mich rechtzeitig noch gewehrt. Du bist vom Stuhl gefallen, weil du so in dem Wirbel, in der Schwerelosigkeit dieser Figur verloren warst gar. Ich musste Mund-zu-Mund-Beatmung an dir vollbringen. Ich war etwas panisch, das haben sie wahrscheinlich gemerkt, aber letzten Endes, glaube ich, ist es Beweis der unglaublichen Performance, die die beiden gegeben haben. Deswegen haben wir den Moderationspreis 2014 bekommen. Das musst du ja nicht immer erwähnen. Das merkt die Leute ja auch, dass wir einfach das fähig sind.
Oh, wir sind Tränen beim Eiskunstlaufpark.
Oh nein.
Wird es Freudentränen oder sind es die Schmerztränen?
Und sie sind gefroren, die Tränen sind komplett gefroren, noch auf der Wange.
Zack, was?
Ich bin ganz hypnotisiert.
Okay, Stefan, Stefan.
So wird das nichts mit dem Moderatorenpreis 2016.
Das war das Turnier 2015.
Das war völlig richtig, das Turnier 2015.
Nicht, dass ihr da alle durcheinander kommt.
Und dann sind wieder grosse Diskussionen in den Kommentaren, die Wurme soll er sparen.
Es gibt ja auch Ringe, zum Beispiel, also ich bin ja großer E-Sport-Fan von Dota zum Beispiel. Dota, D-O-T-E-R. Dota. Und wer Dota gewinnt, der kriegt einen Ring auch. Was? Den tragen die in der Regel nicht, aber man kriegt einen Ring. Den einen Ring? Es gibt dann fünf Ringe, so ein Dota-Team besteht ja aus fünf Leuten, und dann kriegt man einen Ring, aber ich glaube, es gibt es auch beim Football und so, also ich glaube, Ring ist gängig. Ich finde das zu speziell, das ist die alte Frage, also klar, wenn man jemanden sehr gut kennt, kann man sehr spezielle Sachen schenken, das finde ich auch schöner als so dieser Generic Gutschein oder Geld, aber die Veranstalter kennen jetzt ja nicht unbedingt, oder macht persönliche Geschenke. Du weisst das sehr gerne, du hast das sehr reitet und brauch einen neuen Sattel für sein Pferdchen. Stopp, das heißt, du musst dir für jeden möglichen Gewinner ein persönliches Geschenk überlegen. Woher ich gedanklich komme? Das ist die schlimmste Idee, die ich je gehört habe. Stell dir vor, Champions League Finale, du hast elf Geschenke in blau, du hast elf Geschenke in rot. Und Form verrät schon viel. Offensichtlich ein Pferd, weil Carsten sich ein Pferd anscheinend wünscht und dann stehst du da und du denkst dir, okay, wer gewinnt jetzt und irgendjemand, irgendein Praktikant hat jetzt richtig Stress, all diese 22 Geschenke zu organisieren. Moment mal, wie? Sie wechseln Drechsler aus? Sie wechseln Drechsler aus? Scheiße. Oh nein. Scheiße, ich hatte ihm extra diese Taschenlampe, die man sich über die Stirn binden kann, geschenkt. Sie wechseln Drechsler durch Riebelsburger aus? Riebelsburger, ähm, was kann man Riebelsburger, hat jemand eine Idee, hat jemand eine Idee? Okay, ich weiss nicht, Amazon Gutschein. Nein, das muss spezieller sein, was... Preisgeld, Riebelspreisgeld, Pokal. Nein, nein, nicht in Pokal. Oder mag er besonders Medaillen, mag er Medaillen? Nee, ich glaube nicht, keine Ahnung, ich glaube, das ist, was man halt schenkt. Wie wäre es mit so, so, so Duft, so Duftholzstöcken, die man so in so Vasen... Sehr speziell, vielleicht mag er den Duft nicht. Okay, Riebelsbacher, kennt ihr irgendjemand Riebelsbacher hier? Ja, ja. Du, du, wer ist das Rebelsbacher für ein Typ? Ja, ich habe gehört, dass er gerne Gesellschaftsspiele spielt. Okay, sehr gut. Das heißt, er hat schon viele? Ja, er hat schon sehr viele. Also sieht das von Katan die Klassiker. Ja, die anderen natürlich schon, ja. Gibt es ein Gesellschaftsspiel mit Fussball? Monopoly-Fussball oder so, Monopoly-Champions League, sowas. Ich kenne mich damit nicht so richtig aus, ne. Okay, okay, ähm, sonst noch was, außer Brechtspiel? Ich drücke nur auf die Tröte, wenn ein Tor fällt. Ah, okay. Also mehr habe ich, das ist immer eine ganze Kompetenz. Okay, dann hast du ja heute nicht viel zu tun. Ja, nee, es steht 0-0, ich weiß. Ich bin ready, also wenn ein Tor fällt, dann drücke ich dir aufs Nebelhorn. Okay, dann lassen Sie einen Gutschein für ... Ja, ich finde es völlig okay. Aber halt was, was er mag. Gutschein für ... Dann den Hamburg Dungeon. Den Hamburg Dungeon zum Beispiel. Ja, weiß ich nicht. Weiß ich nicht. Wenn der FC Bayern-Spieler auch mal nach Hamburg kommt, warum denn nicht? Moment, was? Tor, drei Tore drei Tore gefallen, drei Tore gleichzeitig, oh, sie liegen 3-0 hinten, die ganzen Geschenke umsonst. Ich denke mir nur, Kai Havert zum Beispiel, er hat ja Esel, Kai Havert ist ein Fussballspieler, der hier immer mit seinem FC St. Pauli, du kommst mit so einem Mantel, so einem Fussballermantel, Daunenmantel. Ja und spielt der bei Pauli oder was? Nein, aber ich dachte, du bist ja so ein Fussballgame drin. Was ist das für ein Zeichen? Pauli hat doch diesen Gnochenkopf. Ach so. Das ist das Zeichen für den FC Pauli. Vorhin kreuzt ein bisschen gemein, wie so ein Schulbully, beide Finger. Hör auf damit! Warum? Das ist keine beleidigende Geste, das steht für Pauli. Ich finde das sieht beleidigend aus. Für jemanden, der es nicht weiss, denke ich mir, du zeigst mit dem Finger, zwei Finger sogar. Ich hatte einmal in meinem Leben mit Fussball zu tun, seitdem habe ich einen guten Freund, der ist Fussball-Bundesligaspieler, der spielt bei St. Pauli und ich habe so eine Jacke bekommen, die ich ganz gerne trage. Aber alles an dem Sack des Spiels für den FC St. Pauli. Ja, das stimmt. Ich trage dann immer so eine Jacke mit dem FC St. Pauli-Logo drum, was natürlich auch immer Spaß macht. Die niemand hat, außer St. Pauli-Spieler. Genau, und du wirst halt einmal böse angeschaut und immer wenn du an so Fußballplätzen vorbeischaust, dann gucken schon alle so und dann stelle ich mich mit so einem kleinen Notizblock hin und coache so ein bisschen und schaue mal so ein bisschen, ob Spieler dabei sind. Und hoffst, dass der Ball nicht über den Zaun fliegt, weil du ihn zurückwirfst, weil du nicht schießen kannst. Genau. Kopfball. Ich glaube, ich würde ihn so ganz hoch in die Luft werfen und dann versuchen mit dem Kopfball über den Zaun. Ja, das will ich, also ich bete nicht so häufig zu Gott, ich bin kein gläubiger Mensch, aber sobald ich an so Basketball, Fussball, wir machen alle den Ton aus Minute 16 wenn ich mal an sowas vorbeikomme, bete ich wirklich zu Gott, dass der Ball nicht in meine Richtung fliegt. Und schon so oft flog er genau in meine Richtung. Weil Gott sagt, nee, dafür bin ich nicht da. So, Kinder, was haben wir heute? Drei Briefe? Alle drei von Stefan Tietze? Ja, und die Leitung blinkt die ganze Zeit schon, also da kommen irgendwie Gebete rein oder so. Okay, was haben wir hier? Stefan Tietze. Oh, meine Brille hier. Warum brauchen Sie eine Brille eigentlich? Sie sind doch allmächtig. Na ja, ich bin auch schon eine Weile unterwegs. Ist das Glas? Ich bin auch schon eine Weile im Job. Ist doch einfach Glas. Ja. Tragen Sie aus einfach modischen Gründen eine Brille. Ja gut, das ist ja auch, also ich meine, das hat ja auch einen Stil. Ich gehe auch mit der Zeit. Nee, natürlich. Glaubst du, ich bin doch der Rüssel-Typ von 5.000 Jahren oder was? Nein, nein, nein. Soll ich den Dreizack wieder auspacken? Nein, nein, nein, nein. Ich kann auch mit der Zeit gehen oder nicht? Ja klar, wer nicht mit der Zeit geht, muss mit der Zeit. Nee, natürlich. Glaubst du, ich bin doch der Rüssel-Typ von vor tausend Jahren oder was? Soll ich den Dreizack wieder auspacken? Ich kann auch mit der Zeit gehen, oder nicht? Ja, klar, wer nicht mit der Zeit geht, muss mit der Zeit gehen. So, Stefan Tietze wünscht sich, bitte lass den Ball von den Fünftklässlern nicht in meine Richtung rollen. Weißt du, ich kann Krebs halten. Ich kann Naturkatastrophen abwenden. Warum haben Sie noch nie, haben Sie beides noch nie gemacht? Ja, weil mich niemand frägt.
Nerv, okay, Sie sind allmächtig, Sie haben offensichtlich grammatikalischen Fehler begangen.
Das heisst, ist das jetzt richtig, also...
Ja, denk mal nach.
Naja, Regel eins ist, Sie haben immer recht.
Ja.
Regel zwei ist... Wenn Regel eins mal nicht klappt, tritt automatisch Regel eins in Kraft. So, wer ist dieser Titzelkerl denn? Was macht er denn so? Er ist so ein grosser, bisschen lauchiger Lauchenberger, der da so rumläuft. Hat er Krebs? Ne, kein Krebs. Ja, nee, machen wir nicht. Nee, komm, gib dem den Ball direkt in die Richtung. Was? Aber das ist das Gegenteil von dem, was er wollte eigentlich.
Ja, nee, der wird schon mal deine Lektionen lernen. Wie Hiob.
Nein, erzähl ich doch an Hiob, oder?
Ja, das war ein Trottel, ey.
Wir hatten eine Woche lang richtig viel zu tun.
Die Frösche, ey, der kriegt jeden Tag einen Frosch ins Gesicht und die Heuschrecken.
Ah, das war gut. Das sollten wir nochmal machen. So, gib dir den Ball. Yeah. Oh, hoffentlich schiessen die den Ball nicht zu mir. Oh, Mensch, Thomas, warum schiessst du immer deine Heben? Entschuldigen Sie, entschuldigen Sie, könnten Sie uns bitte den Ball herrüber schiessen? Ja, Lallemann. Si, claro. Du vog i dobrado ballo. Ah, ja, si. Kann ich ihn auch werfen? No. Warum nicht? Por qué? Di amo es de daro. Ach so, das Loch im Zaun ist genau dafür gemacht, dass man nur durchschiessen kann. Ach so, der Zaun ist zu hoch. Deswegen kann man nicht rüber werfen, man kann nicht rüber schiessen. Das sind neue, die neuen Bolzplätze in Köln. Die sieht man aus dem All, tatsächlich. Ja, tatsächlich. Weil die so hoch sind. Die so ein Schornstein einfach, die steigen bis in die Stratosphäre. Ah, habe ich persönlich gebaut, damit es nicht passiert, dass ich den Ball bekomme. Damit die nicht rausfliegen, okay. Aber jetzt ist es ein bisschen blöd. Ja, so Domes gebaut, sozusagen so, aber mit so Gittern über dem Feld auch. Okay, das ist mal eine grosse Stunde. Ich habe dafür gebetet, aber offensichtlich ist Gott nicht mein Freund. Okay, los geht's. Drei, zwei, eins. Nein, nein, nein! Jetzt liegt er noch weiter weg. Können Sie ihn noch mal schießen? Können Sie ihn noch mal schießen? Das ist mein Albtraum. Jede Nacht war ich schweissgeballert auf, weil ich daran denke. Das ist wirklich schrecklich. Aber es ist auch so ein Ding, wo ich mir denke, wenn der Ball wirklich in meine Richtung fliegen würde, ich würde ihn Volley nehmen und mit voller Wucht treten und dann ist es auch nicht mehr mein Problem. Ich würde glaube ich wirklich all in gehen, alles in diesen einen Schuss legen und dann irgendwie zu Baser-mäßig den irgendwie so zwei Minuten in der Luft stehen lassen und damit er einfach rüber geht. Ich müsste gerade an meinen Traum denken diese Nacht, weil ich weiß nicht, ob du das mitbekommen hast, aber Jürgen Klopp hat ja bekannt gegeben,
dass er nicht mehr Trainer,
Ende der Saison nicht mehr Trainer, der von Liverpool ist
und aufhört. Und das
hat mich ihm wieder dazu gebracht, so ein bisschen
mich reinzunerden, irgendwie
manchmal reicht es. Wenn er jetzt aufhört, dann nerdest du dich rein,
oder was? Das schlechteste Timing, oder was?
Als Dortmunder jung. Sieht sich zurück, oh, okay,
über den muss ich alles wissen.
Und gucken, was jetzt passiert. Nein, aber so, ich finde es einfach spannend. Er ist ein super krasnischer, cooler Kerl und ein toller Trainer, da habe ich viel drüber jetzt gelesen. Und ich bin ja auch schon Fan, seitdem ich Dortmunder Jungen, klar ist man ja Jürgen Klopp-Fan. Der macht ja vieles, auch sehr unkonventionell und ist ein sehr unkonventioneller Coach. Und ich bin dann, wie ich bin und nerde mich dann immer rein in ein Thema, gerade auch lustigerweise deswegen Fussball und bin dann so sehr fokussiert darauf. Heißt, in meinen Träumen verarbeite ich oft diese speziellen Themen. Also mein Gehirn macht aus Jürgen Klopp und unkonventionell folgenden Traum.
Habe ich heute wirklich geträumt und ich konnte nicht mehr darüber lachen, weil ich so perplex war. Ich habe geträumt, ich sehe ein Spiel von Jürgen Klopp gegen eine andere Mannschaft aus England. Er hat gespielt? Nee, nee, nee, er hat trainiert. Trainerbank? Genau, und dann hat er bei Nationalmannschaften trainiert oder sowas. Jedenfalls, weil er halt unkonventionell sein wollte, wollte er nicht, er hat Deutschland trainiert, wollte er nicht die deutsche Nationalmannschaft spielen, sondern hat irgendwie gegen England gespielt, die haben ihre Hymne gespielt und haben die Hymne gesungen, God Save the King. Sehr gut, das war ein aktueller Traum. Ja, aktueller Traum. Und dann war die Deutsche dran, Deutschland dran und weil er halt der unkonventionelle Trainer ist, hat er sich gesagt, nein, wir singen nicht die deutsche Nationalmannschaft, wie es wir immer gemacht haben, sondern die Titelmusik von biene maya okay und dann lief vollen ernstes in diesem traum haben alle vollen ernstes inbrünstig und er auch mit diesem ernsten jürgen klopp blick hat er dann hat er dann und diese biene die ich meine Kleine, frische, schlaue Biene, Maya, Maya! Und es macht ja Sinn, weil es ist ein deutscher Song. Es ist ein deutscher Song und ich habe ihn nur so ernst gesehen und nichts daran war, hat gesagt, er ist gerade albern, lustig. Ich habe auch die Fernsehübertragung gesehen, da war es auch kein Thema, also irgendwie war es so völlig settled. Da bin ich aufgewacht und dachte mir, ich mag fucking ernst sein. Und ich mag es auch nicht, über Träume zu reden im Podcast, ich finde es billig, weil man kann sich alles ausdenken, ich finde es albern, so ein bisschen. Und wenn ich selber zuhöre bei anderen Podcasts, denke ich mir immer, Traum, Traum, Traum, alles ist weird, es ist nicht lustig, aber dabei... Ich finde es gut, dass das deine Version von unkonventionell ist. Also, Herr Klopp, wir haben jetzt zwölf Seiten Konzeptpapier zur Hymne bekommen, aber nichts zum Spiel, also naja, wenn Sie mir eine Frage Friedrichsen beantworten wollen, dann doch wo beginnt das Spiel? Na ja, bei Minute null. Bei Minute eins. Das Spiel beginnt Formspiel. Und was ist direkt unmittelbar vorm Spiel? Vorm Spiel ist vorm Spiel, sagen sie immer. Vorm Spiel ist vorm Spiel. Okay. Die Hymnen. Ja. Ja, wir singen die Hymnen. Okay. Ja, das ist doch glasklar. Ja, ich verstehe schon. Aber sie haben ja gar nichts zum Spiel, da ist alles leer. Das ist auch gut. Die Spieler sind gut. Das ist die deutsche Nationalmannschaft. Natürlich sind die Spieler gut. Sie können alle kicken. Sie haben eine komplette Partitur von Biene Maier aus dem Kopf geschrieben.
Ich habe es unarrangiert. Die Jungs können alle kicken, das ist klar. Es ist hier oben, Kopfproblem. Das grösste Sportorgan des Menschen ist oben, im Kopf hier, ist Gehirn. Wirklich? Die meisten Nerven-Sportenden sind im Gehirn, oder was? Die meisten Sportenden sind hier oben, Nerven-Sportenden sind hier oben im Kopf. Ach, das wüsste ich ja gar nicht. Und bitte, Sie dürfen niemals aufhören, Herr Klopp. Sie dürfen bitte nie, nie, nie aufhören, weil Sie können dem Fussball noch so viel geben. Stefan, Schatz, warum schläfst du so unruhig? Warum schläfst du so unruhig? Was träumst du denn? Schatz, ich habe... Hast du einen Albtraum? Ich hatte einen Albtraum.
Ich habe gehört, ich habe geträumt, dass Jürgen Klopp die deutsche Nationalmannschaft komplett unkonventionell umgestaltet hat. Aber selbst in diesem Albtraum hätte er niemals aufgehört, Trainer zu sein.
Ich bin nicht deine Freundin, ich bin Jürgen Klopp.
Oh nein!
Ich glaube, ich hatte in einem Traum.
Inception zwei.
Jetzt kommt Jürgen.
Jürgen legt los.
Jürgen.
Inception zwei.
Ach ja. Okay, aber das heißt, er ist jetzt raus und du kannst da auch nichts mehr machen. Also willst du eine Petition starten, eine Unterschriftenliste? Er ist wie Ratzinger, hat sich entschieden, er hat nicht mehr genug Energie für diesen Job und möchte das deswegen machen. Und ich finde es auch cool, in einem Sport, wo alle immer gefeuert werden, selbst gute Trainer und er sagt einfach, nö, ich gehe entscheidend. Aber kannst du nicht sagen, die haben nicht das gemacht, was ich ihnen gesagt habe, wenn du verlierst? Ja, als Trainer kann man sich immer leicht rausreden, finde ich auch. Stand ich auf dem Platz? Habe ich das Tor nicht geschossen? Ja, habe ich daneben geschossen? Habe ich ihn wieder verkackt? H bin jetzt falsche tor geschossen habe ich habe ich schweiss im gesicht also habe ich gespült moment moment kann ich meine schuhe an sich aus was habe ich für den preis für the most sassy coach geht an floridin welt jedes mal oder eben spielt habe ich ein trikot an ist das gelb ja bin ich farben blind plötzlich ja wir bezahlen als ihr vereinschef muss ich Ihnen sagen, wir geben Ihnen sehr viel Geld dafür. Hast du gerade zur Tür geguckt, weil ich mich ausfassieren gegen den? Ja, Alter, das klopft dir mal an. Hast du gerade zu unserer Glastür geguckt, weil ich an unseren Holztisch gekommen bin? Ich dachte, es kommt jemand rein, vielleicht haben wir noch einen Überraschungsgast. Ich bin, ich bin Ihr Vereinschef. ne okay ich bezahle Ihnen eine grosse Summe Geld dafür, dass Sie die Jungs trainieren. Und wir da draußen gewinnen. Und Sie reden immer mit draußen mit, habe ich ein Träger? Nein. Also Sie sagen, es werden zu wenig Tore geschossen, oder wie? Naja, wir verlieren. Okay, Moment mal, was habe ich für Socken an? Welche Socken habe ich an? Sind es Fussballer? Moment mal, hä? Komisch, Tommy Hilfiger steht hier drauf. Ja, Sie müssen was reden hier. Das sind doch keine, Fussballer würde doch nicht mit einem Lacoste-Hemd aufs Spielfeld gehen, oder? Ja, sehen Sie das anders, sehen Sie es anders. Sehen Sie es anders. Nein, ich sehe es nicht anders. Aha, okay, dann schaue ich mal ganz kurz an mein Handgelenk. Rolex. Aha. Das auf dem Fussballplatz? Ungewöhnlich. Sie kriegen zu viel Geld. Ungewöhnlich. Ich wette ja auf die Spiele. Sie wetten auf ihre eigenen Spiele? Nein! Wetten sie gegen uns? Meine Frau. Ich gebe immer mit meiner Frau immer Tipps und sage, der Junge kann nichts. Der schießt heute kein Tor. Ja. Das darf man nicht sagen. Hast du schon mal gewettet? Hast du schon mal gewettet? Ja. Auf Sportwett? Ja, ich mache es so richtig. Einmal im Jahr, nee, stimmt nicht, zweimal im Jahr. Aber auf beide Teams. Manchmal kommen Freunde vorbei und wir gucken Tennis. Also irgendwie, warum auch immer. Ich guck dann eigentlich nur das Finale und dann kommen ein paar Freunde vorbei und dann guckt man das. Und da ist ein Freund dabei, der gerne wettet. Und dann wetten wir ab und zu. Stellen wir euch vor, so fünf klassische, mit zwanziger Studenten-Typen und ein so ein Typ so, hä Leute, hä, hä, hä, wollen wir ein bisschen wetten, hä, schmeiß mal ein paar Dollar in den Ring, hä, habt ihr Lust, würfeln wir ein bisschen. Und einfach so, warum ist der Typ immer, hä, Leute, hä, komm, schmeißt mal hier einen Zehner in die Runde. Kann man hier mit einem Zehnerlein, Ja, klar, ich lehne dir einen Zehner, kriegst du morgen 20 Euro, kommst mal her.
Warum fasst du dich ständig an die Nase und machst Pfff? Nee, es ist sogar der liebe Freund Christian Huber, den wir alle gut kennen. Ach was, oh, und der zockt alle ab, oder was? Ich weiß gar nicht, ob der überall viel wettet, soll er selber sagen. Nein, er bringt keinen Hut mit. aber er hat mich er animiert mich dann immer dieses eine mal wenn wir zusammen tennis gucken
dazu zu wetten was er immer so abläuft bringt keinen Hut mit. Aber er hat mich, er animiert mich dann immer dieses eine Mal,
wenn wir zusammen Tennis gucken,
dazu zu wetten, was dann immer so abläuft,
dass er, wir gucken dann, wenn wir
das Gefühl haben, ah okay, das Spiel kippt gerade,
gucken wir, wie gerade die Quoten
stehen und wetten dann auf den,
der meistens hinten liegt,
weil wir das Gefühl haben, jetzt ist gerade ein Momentum-Shift,
der jetzt, jetzt
redet er durch, jetzt haben wir, jetzt hat er im Spiel angekommen und jetzt besiegt er den.
Und dann, weil Christian diese App hat, sagt er dann, wollen wir darauf wetten, ja, jeder ein Fünfer, ja, und dann sage ich nur ja, er wettet zehn Euro, Fünfer von mir, Fünfer von ihm, und dann haben wir jeweils immer gewonnen, dann sind sie so 36 Euro oder so gewonnen und er überweist mir Geld.
Und das Lustige ist, es fühlt sich so komisch an, weil für denjenigen, der diesen Prozess durchläuft, diese App auf dem Handy hat, die Wette platziert, sich durchtippt, Geld überweist, was dann kurz weg ist, weißt du, ich aber, der daneben sitzt und sagt, ja, nee, können wir machen, klar, können wir machen, macht nichts und kriegt Geld überwiesen. Es fühlt sich so lustig an, weil dieses ganze zum Wettbüro gehen, jetzt ist es was passiert virtuell in dieser App, aber es ist so ein Ding und so ein Investment und man hat dieses Risiko, aber ich sag ja nur, ja, können wir schon machen und kriegt dann Geld. ja das ist irgendwiewürdig und voll das tolle Gefühl und ich will es jedes Mal machen.
Ich will es jetzt machen.
Aber bei so einer Tennisübertragung
man sieht das Feld nie so
quer.
Es ist immer oben ist der eine, unten ist der andere, es ist nie
links ist der eine, rechts der andere. Schade, ne?
Weil ich will ja eigentlich dieses Hin und her gucken
bei Tennis so, ansonsten
ist es ja so ein
sitzt ihr dann zu fünft auf dem Sofa und nickt dann so
oder was, wenn der Ball immer so hoch und
Vielen Dank. ich will ja eigentlich dieses hin und her gucken bei tennis so ansonsten ist es ja so ein sitzt ihr dann zu fünft auf dem sofa und nickt dann so oder was wenn der ball immer so hoch und runter geht oder was ja was man zu missverständnissen führt hey will noch jemand eine pizza okay also alle zwei alle gerade erst eine pizza mit noch jemandem milchreis ja okay pizza und milchreis Milchreis. Moment, erst in, Moment, Milchreis, ich habe hier einen mit Kirsche, ja, Zimt. Alle? Hä? Kirsche und, Moment, Kirsche und Zimt auch, beides, Ananas? Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment, stopp, stopp, stopp. Da kommt die Zeitlupe von rechts nach links und alle mit dem Kopf nach links. Okay, okay, keine Ananas, nur Zimt, okay, ich lese mal vor, Zimt, wie jetzt doch nicht. Stopp, ich fang nochmal an. Fünf Milchreis. Ich muss ja gerade an Milchreis denken, weil ich war mal an so einem deutschen Strand und es war ein richtig schöner Tag. So richtig Urlaubsatmosphäre. Ich zähle alle auf. Wangerooge, Spieke-Rooge, Spieke-Rooge. Ich war da eher so Anhängsel, sagen wir mal. Ich hatte wenig Entscheidungsgewalt an dem Tag. Ich war so eins über dem Hund. Anders als sonst, wo du immer ... Ich war so eins über dem Hund. Ich wusste zumindest, dass wir irgendwo hinfahren. Der Hund kann sein, okay, ich werde jetzt einfach in Fleischwolf geschmissen. Keine Ahnung. Aber wir waren so am Strand und da gibt es ja am Strand immer so dann Touristen und so
gute Laune und dann gibt es ja da so Strandbars,
da gibt es dann irgendwie Hotdogs, Eis,
Getränke und bei einem, da waren dann
so laminierte
Pappspeisekarten und dann waren so grosse
Bilder von allen Sachen, die es gab da an der Wand
und da gab es dann irgendwie so Toast Hawaii,
Hotdog,
Burger, Milchreis,
Früchte-Drinks und ich dachte mir, Milchreis? Milchreis am Strand? Das war für mich so merkwürdig, dass jemand sagt, ja, einmal für alle, ich hätte gerne 19 Milchreis, einfach mal für alle. Aber warum? Jeder hat so seinen Napf. Wie hast du das denn abgespeichert als was? Jeder hat seinen Napf Milchreis. Ich hatte es abgespeichert als, das kann doch nicht sein.
Niemand sitzt gerne am Strand mit einer Schüssel heissem Milchreis.
Doch, ich kenne das nämlich auch vom Strand. Wirklich? Auch vom Strand.
Ernsthaft? Vielleicht bin ich zu selten am Strand, aber für mich ist... Das ist das Strandgericht.
Moment mal, ernsthaft?
Also ich verstehe da irgendwie so ein Toast oder irgendwas, was man so in der Hand halten kann, aber mit so einem Napf heissem Milchreis am Schrank. Warum? Warum? Dieser Hitzeaspekt ist mir gar nicht so wichtig.
Also du, aber du hast ja auch noch nie diesen Gulasch oder irgendwie sowas. Warum Milchreis?
Ich weiss auch nicht, es ist halt eine deutsche Süssspeise, ne?
Ja, aber das ist doch ein Eis, ist doch was Kaltes.
Es ist halt einer der drei grossen deutschen, ne, aber es gibt ja... Ist ein Eisbecher oder sowas. Ne, aber es geht ja nicht um den Dessert-Aspekt, sondern Leute wollen ja auch was, eine richtige Mahlzeit am Strand, also eine warme Mahlzeit. Ich sag mal, Hotdog ist ja auch warm. Also der Hitze-Aspekt kann es ja nicht sein. Ja, aber den Hotdog hältst du in der Hand, kannst rumlaufen, irgendwie kannst du irgendwie mitnehmen zu deinem Handtuch. und mit dem Milchreis kriegst du dann so einen Becher und einen Löffel und dann gibst du es wieder ab oder nimmst. Das ist ja völliger Wahnsinn. Also ich kann mir das nicht, also ich hätte fest damit gerechnet, dass wenn ich sage, ich hätte gerne einmal den Milchreis und der Verkäufer so, äh was? Ja, der Milchreis steht, der Milchreis für fünf Euro90 Euro. Den, ja, nee, was wollen Sie wirklich? Ja, den Milchreis, der steht doch da oben auf der Karte. Ist man ernsthaft, den Milchreis? Ja, warum steht der denn? Antonio! Antonio! Si! Es ist so weit. Jemand will den Milchreis. Ja, wir haben keinen. Komme? Niemand nimmt den Milchreis. Niemand nimmt den Milchreis. Antonio? Ich muss kurz nach ihm sehen. Oh nein! Das Bum-Bum! Er hat sich mit dem Kaugummi umgebracht. Wie? Entschuldigung, wir müssen jetzt schliessen. Warum? Weil sie Milchreis bestellt haben. Sie Monster. Wer isst denn Milchreis am Strand? Warum steht es an der Tafel? Die ist handgeschrieben. Darüber steht Tagesgericht. Was ist heute geschrieben worden dann. Rabatt, 30 Prozent.
Auf Pro Korn.
Pro Milchkorn?
Pro Milchkorn, ja.
Das ist kein Unterschied.
Aber das wäre für mich eine Red Flag.
Das wäre für mich eine Red Flag.
Milchreis am Strand?
Matterfact Check.
Das wäre genau der gleiche Preis.
Egal, ob auf jedem Korn oder auf das ganze Gericht 30 Prozent.
Das wäre der gleiche Preis.
Das kommt jetzt mal Podcast UFO. Was ist Mathe-Fact-Check? Mathe-Fact-Check. Okay, Mathe-Fact-Check. Es ist egal, ob man zweimal drei oder dreimal zwei rechnet, es kommt immer das gleiche bei raus. Mathe-Fact-Check. Mathe-Fact-Check. Nein, es muss schon einen direkten Bezug zu den Dingen gehabt haben, die wir davor gehabt haben.
Okay.
Dann darf jeder einfach was, was sie ihm am Mathe wasserweiss sagen.
Ja, okay.
Ich habe auch das Gefühl, dass wir dann besser, also wir kommen ein bisschen schlauer rüber.
Ich glaube das Gefühl, wir kommen manchmal ein bisschen bescheuert rüber.
Weil wir einfach, weil das ja wie eine Art Privatgespräch hier und ich glaube schon, dass jeder irgendwie im Privatgespräch ein bisschen dusselig rüberkommt, weil man ja schon irgendwie so labert, wie einem der Mund gewachsen ist. Ja, das mag ich aber auch so an dir. Ich auch. Das mag ich ja so an dir, dass du hier keinen Maulkorb dir anschnallst, dass du dir nicht irgendwie den Maulkorb umschnallst, bevor du hier das Mikro anknallst. Ich sag die Dinge, wie sie sind. Ich sag die Dinge, wie ich sie denke. Ja, ja. So rede ich auch zu Hause. Ja, du Freischnauze! Ich rede so nicht, wenn ich reden will. Freischnauze. Du bist immer ehrlich. Ich habe das Gefühl, manchmal kommen wir nicht so klein darüber. Deswegen habe ich diese Idee mit diesen Mathe-Fact-Checks. Okay, aber es sind nur Mathe-Fact-Checks oder können wir auch mal so in Geografie, weil es ist ja nicht wirklich ein Factcheck, ist einfach ein Funfact, es ist einfach
nur Fact. Ja. Fact.
Aber Factcheck ist so, klingt
cool. Okay, aber ja, du hast recht, das ist ja
Matterfact. Okay,
machen wir einen Geografiecheck kurz.
Ähm, Leute,
der schiefe Turm von Pisa
ist gar nicht schief. Ist ja gar nicht schief.
Ist nur schief, wenn man ihn vom Westen anguckt.
Weil wenn er noch...
Er ist ja nicht in alle...
Man kann ja nicht in...
Das Kerzenständerproblem.
Stopp, man kann nie aus allen Perspektiven schief sein.
Nee, glaube ich auch nicht. Se-minütige Stille. Egal, das finde ich aber einen schönen Spruch. Egal, wie schief du dich fühlst, es gibt immer eine Perspektive, aus der wirkst du nicht schief. Finde ich auch toll. Okay? Ja. Egal, wie schräg du bist. Wenn du dich mal schief fühlst, musst du vielleicht nur die Perspektive ändern. Nee, schräg. Oder weil schräg... Der schräg Turm... Nein, ich weiß. Der quere Turm von Pisa. Also das ist kein Geografie-Factcheck. Aber egal wie schräg du bist, es gibt immer eine Perspektive, aus der du gerade aussiehst. Also die Frage, will rufst irgendwie dafür auf. Schräg kann auch positiv sein, schief ist eigentlich immer negativ. Wenn dir was schief ist, ist es immer eher so, finde ich nicht gut. Okay, egal wie schief du bist und wie schief du dich fühlst, egal wie schief dich Leute angucken, es gibt immer eine Perspektive, aus der die Blicke doch gerade aussieht. Was ist, dass die angucken. Aber du hast recht, der schiefe Turm von Pisa sieht aus. Eigentlich das müsste man als Foto machen, oder? Wenn ich in Pisa wäre, ich würde ein Foto vom Turm machen, aus dem Winkel, aus dem man nicht schief wirkt. Und dann so ein Check, so ein grüner Check, dann. Ja, oder so, ich will mein Geld zurück, oder? Ich will meine Autofahrt zurück. Ich will meine 280 Kilometer Benzin wieder zurück. Turm von Pisa. Der Turm von Pisa. Ja, genau. Pisa-Turm. Aber das heißt, wenn er von Osten gerade ist, ist er auch von Osten ja auch gerade. Von Osten gerade ist er von Westen, wenn Osten schief ist, ist er von Westen auch schief. Du hast gerade gesagt, von Westen sieht der Turm gerade aus. Dann sieht er von Osten auch gerade aus. Ist das jetzt ein Mathe-Fact oder ein Himmelsrichtungs-Fact? Aber er sieht sich, aber ganz gerade sieht er nicht aus, ne? Weil er sieht schon aus, als würde er sich dünnern. So nach hinten neigen, meinst du, wie so eine Schanze? Ja. Wir müssen da mal hin. Wir müssen da mal hin und einfach mal alles rauslassen. Alle witzigen Fotos und alles da mal rauslassen. Habe ich oft gehört, kann man skippen. Es war so neulich so ein Gespräch gehabt, irgendwie Urlaubspläne und ich so, ja, kann man mal vielleicht Italien oder sowas. Ja, Turm, also macht er da, Toskana ist cool, Schiefturm von Pisa, kannst du skippen. Und dann hat er so weitergesprochen. Ich fand das so vernichtend, diesem alten Denkmal gegenüber. Und dann auch so spannend, weil es war nicht so ein Gespräch unter Freunden, die sich seit Jahren kennen, sondern es war so ein Scan, wie die Person mich wahrgenommen hat. Und dann so kam unten raus, er braucht den schiefen Turm von Pisa nicht sehen. Das fand ich so interessant. Dieses Assessment, was dann kam, was das Gehirn ausgespuckt hat, fand ich so spannend. Das finde ich hart. Nee, kannst du skippen. Das ist nichts für dich. Nee, kannst du skippen, das brauchst du nicht. Weihnachtsmann existiert nicht. Genau wie immer man zu mir gesagt hat, Bolognaologna ist deine Stadt. Genau, Bologna und Palermo ist deine Stadt. Und das ist mir so, why, why, warum, warum Palermo? Das ist deine Stadt. Palermo ist meine Stadt. Aber interessant, welche Städte man als Beleidigung wahrnimmt. Bautch, also, ja. Bottrop ist deine Stadt.
Ich glaube, Rostockberg ist genau deine Stadt.
Genau deine Stadt. Wieso? Einfach so.
Bregenz, genau deine Stadt. Warum Bregenz?
Ab wann würde man sagen, hey, stopp mal,
ist das gerade, ist das gerade
noch ein Geografie-Fact-Check oder ist das eine
Beleidigung? Ab wann geht man ins Mobben
über? Duisburg.
Duisburg, ey, Duisburg ist deine
Stadt. Duisburg wäre genau deine Stadt. Warum sagst du das? Cottbus, deine Stadt. Ich kenne die Städte alle nicht, deswegen weiss ich jetzt gar nicht, was ich damit sage. Ehrlich gesagt, aber du fängst nicht viele Kommentare. Aber Palermo ist meine Stadt. Aber klingt schon mal gut. Palermo, sonniges Palermo, das ist schon mal gut. Heiss, wahnsinnig heiß. Ja, auch cool. Super warm, finde ich gut. Aber ich habe auch gehört, es ist sehr rough. Rau im Sinne von einer harte Gegend oder was, raues Pflaster? Du meinst doch jetzt Banden oder was, Bandenkriege? Ja, Mafiosi ist doch die Hauptstadt der Mafiosi. Ach so, ich dachte, das ist eher so Sizilien oder so, wo die so herkommen. Ist Palermo. Fact check, yes, geography, fact check, here we go. Ich habe dich elaborate in diese Einwandstraße-Anekdote geführt, um dich hinten zu erschießen. Sehr gut, ich glaube, du würdest sehr gut nach Palermo passen. Smile statt, nice, wow, das war so rund jetzt alles. Ja, das war nicht so rund, schade, dass die Folge nicht jetzt vorbei ist, das wäre so ein Kröner. Ja, ja. Kriegst du, also wenn du jetzt, sag mal, völlig ohne Kontext,
Ja. Kriegst du, also wenn du jetzt, sag mal völlig ohne Kontext, wenn dein Handy klingelt, ist es eher so ein, oh cool, jemand ruft mich an oder oh nee, was jetzt schon wieder? Nee, ich finde es sehr spannend. Ja, okay. Also Telefonat, also Klingeln, Handy klingeln ist für dich eher was Positives? Nee, ich gehe durch sehr viele Emotionen. Ich gehe durch, klingelt gerade mein Handy, also das ist eine grosse verwirrung immer erst mal riesen verwirrung aber jedes mal gleich groß also maximum verwirrung am anfang und ich könnte und ich kann zurückgerufen werden weil gerade die verbindung unterbrochen wäre und jemand ruft mich zurück und es ist offensichtlich mein handy ich wäre immer noch verwirrt ist es mein handy ist ein anderes handy er neun handys am tisch es macht was ist es dann immer große verwirrung ist es jetzt mein Klingelton, wenn ich es auf laut habe, oder ist es gerade meine Hose, die scharpt. Ich meine, Crazy Frog hat heute kaum noch jemand, da bist du schon fast der Einzige. Reng, deng, greg, greg, greg, greg. Ach, Stefan. Und dann ist es so, scharpt meine Hose an meinem Bein, meine Skinny-Jeans an meinem Bein, oder ist es mein Handy, was vibriert? Kennst du diese Em Emotion auch? Ist es wieder der Schlaganfall oder vibriert einfach meine Leiste gerade? Oder was ist hier los? So, und dann gucke ich drauf und wenn ich angerufen werde, ist es natürlich immer erst mal, ach. Mhm. Aber dann, ich bin immer erst mal sehr interessiert, wer mich anruft, hätte ich gesagt. Immer erst mal, ah cool. Kann jeder sein. Aber jemand will mit mir sprechen. Jemand will gerade, dass ich antworte. Und es muss auch noch in der Art wichtig sein, sonst hätte ja irgendwie eine Slack-Nachricht oder so gereicht. Das heißt, jemand braucht mich gerade. Unbekannte Anrufe, unbekannte Nummer, wie reagierst du da? Neugier, neutral, Lust oder? Ne, ich gehe immer, meine Stimme sagt schon, ich vermute einen Scam-Anruf, deswegen gehe ich so fies dran, Tietze, nee, schon Tietze.
Ach so, Tietze.
Tietze?
Ja, guten Tag. Wer ist da bitte? Ja, na, ich halt. und dann merkt man genau wie ich immer so skeptisch bin und auch sehr kurz ab und dann sobald jemand dann sagt, nee, die Frau von der Volksbank, wir hatten gesprochen und dann sofort mein Schiff. Ja, aha, so, hallo, ich habe ja sonst nur mit unangenehmen Ekeln zu tun, aber sie, ach so, ja. Und dann stiftet meine Stimme in Richtung, vielen Dank für den Anruf, Sie sind die beste Person. Danke dass Sie sich noch mal mailen. Ich habe letztens, glaube ich, einen Anruf bekommen, den niemand gerne bekommt. Es gibt ja gleich einfach ein Spektrum, eine Skala von Nummern, die man auf dem Display sieht, von ich freue mich total zu absolut schrecklich. Und ich habe tatsächlich Anruf bekommen von Hausmeister. Und das ist, glaube ich, so der Punkt ganz weit unten. Horror. Und zwar, ich war in Hamburg, krieg einen Anruf von Hausmeister. Und das ist, glaube ich, so der Punkt ganz weit unten.
Und zwar, ich war in Hamburg,
krieg einen Anruf von Hausmeister Köln.
Horror.
Und ich war gerade mitten in der Podcastaufnahme,
hab weggedrückt,
dachte mir, okay, alles in Flammen,
ist irgendwas eingestürzt,
oder irgendwie mein Kleingeld
einmal ist einfach durch den Boden
durchgebrochen und hat meine Nachbarin unter mir erschlagen.
Er ist in Richtung Erdkern geschürzt.
Ist jetzt wirklich bis in den Erdkern eingeschmolzen, enormer Wertverlust, also absolute Katastrophe.
Und dann schaue ich dann auf mein Handy, Sprachnachricht von Hausmeister, meint ja, ihr Nachbar unter ihnen hat sich bei mir gemeldet, da kommt Wasser durch die Karte. Also der absolute fucking worst case. In der Wohnung, wo ich schon eine Weile nicht mehr war, in Köln, weil ich pendle ja immer Köln, Hamburg. Und das war dann schon erstmal so, naja. und dann ist auch die Frage, okay, was macht man jetzt? So fährt man da jetzt sofort hin, weil ich wollte eigentlich noch ein paar Tage bleiben, hatte eigentlich noch nicht geplant, zurückzukommen, so ein Ding. Was ist das jetzt? Ist das bei mir? Man überlegt natürlich schon, bin ich wirklich so dumm und lasse ein Wasserhahn laufen? Nicht unbedingt, kann ja auch ein Rohrbruch sein. Rohrbruch, Wasserkasten oder irgendwas, Waschmaschine, habe ich die Waschmaschine angelassen, bin ich so dumm? Bin ich so dumm? Ja, kann schon sein, irgendwas kann schon sein, bitte nicht ich, bitte nicht ich, bitte nicht ich. Und dann meinte der Hausmeister nochmal, ja, er war jetzt in der Wohnung unten und es reicht, wenn du am Montag kommst, schien also nicht so schlimm
zu sein und ich dachte mir, fuck,
okay, was ist da los und jetzt
war ich in der Wohnung
und bei mir kam auch Wasser
durch die Decke,
ist also durch meine Wohnung
durch in die Wohnung drunter und
absolut ruiniert, alles ruiniert.
Deine Wohnung ist ruiniert? Mehr oder weniger ruiniert.
Am selben Tag kam noch der Installateur, Zitat des Installateurs, holy moly. Im Sinne von, sie klingt, ich stimme vor, wie so ein sehr optimistischer Hausbesitzer auf diesen Typen trifft. Holy moly, im Sinne von, sie klingt das sofort super schnell dahin. Im Sinne von ganz einfach, ich kam heute früher Feierabend.
Im Sinne von, wow, viel schlimmer, was erwartet.
Aber das ist, glaube ich, nicht das, was man von einem Installateur hören will, der deinen Bart anschaut und sagt Holy Guacamole. Holy Guacamole. Aber das Lustige ist, weil ich habe einen Kumpel, dem jetzt was Furchtbares passiert ist, weil er ist ausgezogen und umgezogen in eine neue Wohnung und dann gibt es ja immer diese Phase, wo du vielleicht noch kurz zwei Wohnungen haben musst, weil du es nicht direkt untervermütet bekommst oder irgendwelche Kündigungsfristen oder sowas und in seiner alten Wohnung hatte er die Heizung ausgedreht, komplett. Was ich auch machen würde, weil hier ist ja niemand drin, ich hab keinen Bock mehr jetzt irgendwie zu bezahlen, nämlich Heizkosten für die letzten Monate und ist umgezogen. Er kriegt einen Anruf, die Wohnungen unter ihnen sind komplett unter Wasser, weil es war diese Frostzeit, diese schlimme, wo dann die Heizungen zugefroren sind und das deh das dehnt sich dann aus jeder hat schon mal eine flasche im tiefkühlfach vergessen die dann platzt also es passiert so eine marke flasche zum beispiel und dann platzten die rohre und ich dachte gerade war das über dir war er das über die das wäre auch gut wenn wir jetzt in zusammenhang stehen aber ja absolute katastrophe ganz ganz furchtbar wasser ist ja noch schlimmer manchmal als feuer na das ist eine schwierige diskussion aber als luft ja also das luft allemal als erde würde ich sagen auch. Wasser frisst sich durch, Wasser ist schleichend, Wasser ist, verträgt sich auch gar nicht gut mit Strom, das hat sich auch eine grosse Gefahr.
Das stimmt, ja, ist eine Schwäche von Strom.
Wenn du da reingehst, von was, nee, ist es Stärke von Wasser?
Nee, Wasser hat die Schwäche Strom.
Nee, bei Pokémon ja.
Ja.
Ja, aber so kannst du dir die Welt nicht mehr erklären.
Aber warum nicht andersrum, warum hat Strom nicht die schwäche Wasser?
Ja.
Naja.
Nee, Strom wird stärker mit Wasser.
Aber Wasser wird auch stärker mit Strom.
Also eigentlich sollten die sich beide symbiotisch ...
Ja, aber ja, weiss ich nicht. Ja, schwierig.
Ja, aber ja, interessant.
Weil es stimmt schon, Computer geht kaputt, wenn man Wasser draufkippt.
Also ist der anfällig gegen Wasser, weil er aus Strom ist.
Genau.
Also eigentlich sollte Strom die schwäche Wasser haben.
Vielen Dank. Ja, aber ja, weil es stimmt schon, Computer geht kaputt, wenn man Wasser draufkippt. Also ist der anfällig gegen Wasser, weil er aus Strom ist. Genau. Also eigentlich sollte Strom die schwäche Wasser haben. Genau. Müssen wir alles nochmal neu denken? Ja, wir nicht. Ist Shiggy gut gegen Pikachu? Lass uns mal testen. Lass uns mal testen. Lass uns mal Aquaknare gegen Pikachu einsetzen, bitte. Was mich an diesem unglaublichen Fund gerade hier beruhigt, ist, dass wir daran nichts ändern müssen. Weißt du, wir haben wie was gelöst und so, aber wir müssen uns das nicht irgendwie anpassen. Ja, ja. Boah, okay, und jetzt musst du da raus, oder was? Das ist deine Wohnung in Köln. Pff, es ist halt nicht so cool, aber ... Ist kaputt jetzt. Ja, also was heißt kaputt? Ich sag mal so, viel schlimmer für mich war, dass meine Wohnung halt aussieht wie Sau einfach, weil ich nur aufräume, wenn da Besuch kommt und es halt wirklich einfach aussieht wie Dreck einfach. Und plötzlich steht mein Vermieter und ein Installateur in meiner Wohnung und das war mir am allerunangenehmsten und ich meine, das kann ich noch zehn Minuten kurz aufräumen. Deswegen, paradoxerweise war ich relativ froh über den starken Schaden, weil unter diesem meine Unordnung eher untergegangen ist. Ja, man stellt sich eine X- und Y-Achse vor und deine Wohnung ist so unaufgeräumt,
dass je stärker der
Schaden, desto
mehr verschleiert ist dein
Problem. Richtig, genau, desto mehr lenkt
es von der anderen Katastrophe,
die mein Privatleben ist, ab.
Genau. Und dann sieht man das
nicht mehr so, weil natürlich auch Wasser überall war,
das hat dann alles so ein bisschen durchgewaschen,
das sah nicht so gut aus. Oh nein, das Wasser hat wohl diesen ganzen wäscheberg aufgehäuft oh nein
durch das wasser ist spaghetti bolognese an der wand in der küche das ist dann da so reingeflossen
die von offensichtlich von einem schwer zerschlagene Lampe des Wasser, kennt aber auch gar keine Grenzen.
Oh Gott, und das hat dann die ganzen Pfandflaschen hier reingespült von der Wohnung drüber?
Ja, ja, wir haben ganz andere Probleme hier.
Ach nein!
Wir sind sehr unaufgeräumt, aber es ist nicht so schlimm, wir haben ein anderes Problem.
Da ist Wasser durch die Decke, und dann sind ja so Lampen in der Decke, an der Lampe vorbei, dadurch ist die Lampe gerostet, das Wasser hat den Rost mitgenommen, tropft Rost runter auf die Fliese. Jetzt habe ich Rostflecken auf der Bartfliese, die ich da nicht mehr weckriege. Aber es ist interessant, weil plötzlich hast du so eine ganze geologische Schichten-Architektur,
wo du Dinge
da drin hast, und das ist ja das Eklige eigentlich,
dass das Zeug auf dich drauf tropft
und du denkst, wo ist das schon überall
gewesen, aber das Gegenteil von der
klassischen Mineralwasserwerbung, weil
die sagt ja, oh, das ist einmal durch den Berg gegangen,
durch viele Schichten, Thumbs up, und ich denke mir,
warum? Thumbs down.
Down with the thumbs, put the thumbs down. Viel Schichten ist Thumbs up. Und ich denke mir, warum? Thumbs down. Down with the thumbs. Put the thumbs down.
Viele Schichten ist nicht unbedingt besser. Viel zu viele Schichten. Wo sind Schichten gut? Beulig ist durch so viele Schichten gelaufen. Deiner Torte sind Schichten gut, aber doch nicht bei Wasser. Ich will das der Quelle trinken. Nicht zwischen den ganzen Tieren, die da umgekommen sind im Fluss. Sie haben da rein uriniert!
Was?
Schlichten sind schlecht!
Und genau so habe ich mich gefühlt in dem Moment. Und da blättert natürlich auch die ganze Tapete ab. Es sieht wirklich schrecklich aus. Aber jetzt konnte zumindest das Leck geschlossen werden. Nein, die Dreckige Gippe. Über mir Wohnung war auch nicht da. Tapete. Ach so, über dir auch? Über mir. Wer war denn ursächlich? Ursächlich war der Täter über mir, der völlig fröhlich einfach vor sich hingelebt hat, der von allen nichts wusste, dass er wochenlang einfach allen das Leben ruiniert, wo irgendein Rohr einfach getropft hat. Da hat dann der Installateur mir auch ein Video gezeigt, der meinte, hier, ich habe ein Video gemacht. Weil er war dann in der Wohnung drüber und er meinte, hier, ich habe ein Video gemacht. Dann. Dann zeig mir das Video von so einem Rohr, wo so Wasser rausstippt. Was überall sein könnte. Wo so Wasser raus tropft. Da dachte ich, ja krass. Das ist, das ist es, das ist der Grund. Aber er wollte sich noch mit dir verbrüdern, trotz seiner Wohnung. Er wollte sich auf eine Art mir verbrüdern oder er war stolz, dass er den Täter gefunden hat. Stand bei dir was seine Wohnung?
Im Bad, er ist hauptsächlich im Bad nicht wirklich, es ist ja weiter geflossen, das ist ja das Interessante, dass er weiter fließt zu der Nachbarin unter mir, dass da ja an sich das gar nicht so wasserdicht ist, wie ich dachte. Ich dachte ja, ich komme da an und da fließt irgendwie Wasser aus dem Fenster raus irgendwie, da wie bei Werner oder so, dass da irgendwie alles komplett Wassersturzbachartig darunter fließt, aber das ging einigermaßen, aber mir ist richtig schwindelig geworden auch, da ist dann, also da wird dann auch irgendwie wahrscheinlich Schimmel schon am Start sein und es ist halt so ein richtig unangenehmer Geruch in der Wohnung, so etwas richtig, ja so, wie so eine betonige, und mir ist richtig schwindelig geworden ich musste mir erst mal hinsetzen in die pfütze ja dann dachte ich mir jetzt gehe ich erst mal einkaufen da war ich einkaufen dann glaube ich habe ich einen Promi gesehen der mir entgegengekommen ist und ich habe ganz bene geguckt. Ich habe nur so ganz benebelt geguckt, nur so.
Sogar, was ist vor dich hingebrabbelt? Was hat das?
Was ist das?
Schicht, die Schicht, die Schicht, Wasserschicht, Schaden, Wasserschicht, Schaden.
Währenddessen im anderen Podcast, bei Olli Welke in seinem Podcast, dann habe ich den
Florettin Will gesehen, wie er vor den Wolwig-Flaschen stand im Supermarkt und kopfschüttelnd
davor stand und irgendwas von Schichten erzählt und Dann hat er angefangen, wütend auf diesen Wolvik-Kasten einzutreten. Und dann sind, aber ich weiß nicht, ob es war, aber es sah so aus wie Florentin Will. Und dann kamen die Leute von Rewe und mussten ihn dann rauszerren. Ja, das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen. Na ja, gut, aber das macht Schimmel mit dir. Da wirst wirst du erst mal komplett ... Du meinst, der Schimmel hat in dir schon so parasitär ... Hat in mir schon den Fuss gefangen. Ja, der übernimmt mich und der hat in mir schon den Fuss gefangen. Aber die waren noch so an den ... die mussten noch gucken, so wie ... Genau, die konnten vielleicht nicht Kupplung fahren oder so, der Schimmel ist automatisch gewohnt und dann war aber mit Kupplung in erster Gang, was machen wir jetzt? Die waren so wie Jeff Goldblum und Will Smith bei Independence Day. Exakt so, exakt genau so. Die mussten erst mal gucken, wie funktioniert dieses Raumschiff. Genau, weil du als, ich glaube, du kriegst ja als Schimmelpilz grundlegende Ausbildung nur. Du kriegst einfach Independence Day gezeigt. Das kann auch sein. Training, ein Tag, Independence Day und dann Q&A. Independence Day, Q&A. Ich liebe Independence Day. So ein iconic Film. Was Modelle auch machen mit dir. Modelle? Modelle, ja. Das Weisse Haus, Modell, das in die Luft gesprengt wird. Das sieht auch einfach aus, das stelle ich das CGI. Das ist jetzt nicht, was ich in dem Film so toll finde, die Modelle. Bis du du aus Independence Day gegangen und hast gesagt, die Modelle, die Modelle. Florentin, dieses Meme, Schichten, nein, Modelle, genau, das will ich bei Puffo Meme sehen, findet ihr bei Instagram, Shoutout, vielen Dank. PuffoMeme, sehr, sehr gut. Mach dieses Me mit Drake und dann, und niemand wird's verstehen. Und das ist ja, daran liegt ja der Spaß. Ja, genau. So für uns, für uns ganz kleine Gruppe auf der Welt. Ganz winzig, ganz winzig klein. Ich wünsche dir alles Gute mit deinem Wasserproblem. Alle haben gerade Wasserprobleme. Ich habe mit neun Leuten gesprochen, die Wasserprobleme haben. Wasser ist mein Flop-Element 2024, muss ich sagen. Wir machen ja jedes Jahr Top- und Flop-Elemente, die Top-4-Elemente. Wir erinnern uns noch, 2023 hat ja Erde sehr gut abgeschnitten, aber für dieses Jahr, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen, hat Wasser schon bei mir einen sehr schweren Stand. Mal gucken, was noch den Rest des Jahres 2024 passiert. Jetzt ist ja auch schon Februar! Da kann natürlich noch viel passieren, aber für mich gerade viele Minuspunkte hat Wasser gesammelt, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen. Das glaube ich dir. Richtig viele Minuspunkte. Also das läuft sehr, sehr eins zu eins bei dir ab, ne? Also sehr wie die Liste, wie man die erwarten würde. Und ich habe letztens auch wieder mir gedacht, Mensch, das Wasser schmeckt irgendwie komisch, das schmeckt hier so komisch. Ich glaube, ich kann das hier nicht mehr trinken, ist da irgendwas drin, Kalk oder so, was ist da drin, komisch, war ich woanders, habe da Wasser getrunken, schmeckt auch komisch. Da dachte ich mir, ach, das ist meine Flasche. Und Hörer des Podcasts werden wahrscheinlich jetzt gerade aufjaulen und sagen, exakt das Gleiche ist hier schon mal passiert, mit dem Nusswasser, als mein Wasser nussig geschmeckt hat und neben mir eine Baustelle war. Und ich dachte, ah ja, die haben halt die Nussleitung irgendwie angesägt oder so. Kommt ja vor. Stell sich heraus, nee, meine Flasche war einfach nur vergilbt und verschimmelt. War halt immer die gleiche benutzt. Ich bin sehr, sehr flaschentreu. Sehr, sehr, sehr flaschentreu. Boah, ich hasse das so doll. Wenn ich einmal eine Plastikflasche gefunden habe, ist das meine. Ich weiss, meine Solach. Man soll ja auch diese Mehrwegflaschen benutzen, diese, wie heissen die, Nitrogen oder sowas. Diese typischen Outdoor, diese Dicken, die kennst du auch zum Sport und so. So mal doch. Und die sind bei allen immer blind. So blind. Die sind bei allen immer blind.
Die sind nicht mehr transparent, die sind so blind, weil die so oft benutzt wurden und dann so Mikrokratzer dich draußen bilden und dann sind die schon so, und die Leute nutzen die so lange und ich weiß, die sind gut für die Umwelt und die sind super und trinken auch ewig da raus. Aber für mich haben die das gleiche, die gleichen Vibes wie so ein Mehrweg-Taschentuch, was so Männer früher hatten, die dann immer wieder reingeballert haben. Genau so ist, weil du hast doch im Mund, du willst doch nicht die ganze Zeit an deinen eigenen, du isst ja auch was. Ja, ja, ja, doch. Und dann hast du so einen Döner gegessen, dann trinkst du danach Wasser und danach willst du einfach nur Sport gemacht, machst du auf und hast dann diesen, wieder dieses Salsicha will ich ja nicht mehr Sport dann haben haben ja du bist halt kein treuer typ ich bin treu ich bleib bei meiner flasche ich will ich will das jeden tag und ist natürlich sehr eklig aber du meinst diese diese metallen stahlflaschen dinge da die die glas die gläsernen plexiglasflaschen gläsernen plexiglasflaschen wie heissen denn diese marke nitrogen so. Nitro, nicht Stickstoff. Nitrogen. Nicht das englische Wort für Stickstoff. Moment mal, die haben alle Stickstoff mit dabei, einfach die sind schön Stickstoffschuss oder was? Nalgene, diese Trinkflaschen, hier, Nalgene, Nalgene, was weiß ich, Aua. Aber die sind immer so eklig, blind, die sind immer so gelb teilweise. Und dann trinken sie raus und sagen, oh, da ist irgendwie wohl ein Nüsschen in meine Leitung gekommen. Könnte man nicht einfach Wasserdampf einatmen, anstatt zu trinken? Weil Trinken ist schon nervig. Du kannst ja auch einfach sehr, sehr feuchte Luft einatmen und dann wird sie im Körper auch. Ich will nicht atmen, ich will nicht trinken, ich will so einen Schlauch, den man im Krankenhaus hat, wo hier Sauerstoff rauskommt und dann will ich diese Infusion, wo so einfach nur so was ist das dann? Kochsalzlösung kriegt man so rein und so einen Wassertropf Das sind so pürierte Salamis, die du da so reingepumpt kriegst, einfach so direkt. Dann will ich so einen Helm aufhaben und dann geht mein Mund rein und es tropft wie so eine Bewässerungsanlage, tropft einmal Wasser rein und ich muss nichts mehr machen. Wie so ein Wal, der einfach in seinem Essen schwimmt, einfach nur die Mundaufmacht. Anders als Menschen, die noch auf die Jagd gehen müssen. Ja, na ja, du musst immerhin schon noch hin. Aber hat ein Wal dann auch Hunger und sagt, mir knurrt der Magen. Ja, iss doch was, Schatz. Du musst nur den Mund aufmachen. Jetzt geht's. Aber baut man einen gewissen Hunger auf oder macht man einfach alle fünf Minuten den Klapper auf oder was? Es sind nicht Menschen die einzigen, die nach Hunger handeln, weil alle anderen essen, einfach was, wenn was da ist.
Oh, Biologie-Fact-Check? Nein.
Das war's für diese Woche. Haut rein, habt eine schöne Woche, macht's gut, bis zum nächsten Mal.
Und jetzt bleibt uns nichts anderes mehr übrig, als noch den Turbostarter zu starten.
Hau den Fusionsreaktor an! Steffen, hau noch ein paar Uranscheiben rein!
Los geht's, macht's gut, wir heben wieder ab, tschüss mal so!